Нормальні керівники митниці були, зрозумілі.
А ти, Нефьодов, якийсь керівник митниці такий... дивний.
Щодо співробітників.
Чи вдалося перевести всіх на нову митницю?
У мене дуже простий принцип:
якщо ви вже мультимільйонер, то нащо вам
ця важка неоплачувана державна робота?
Ні, хочуть працювати.
Чи багато контрабандистів вас уже ненавидять?
Я думаю, що багато. Насправді це круто.
Ніхто не заважає вам працювати?
Ніхто не гарантує перемоги, але я радий,
що ми принаймні вийшли на поле бою.
Нова митниця запустилася. Чи є у Вас якесь відчуття успіху?
Насправді це не те, що не перемога.
Це скоріше сам факт  того, що нарешті я офіційно
керую всієї цією структурою, цими  багатьма
тисячами людей, які і працюють в структурі
державної митної служби – центрального апарату
і 16 митниць. Справжні реформи тільки починаються.
Це не означає, що ми гаяли час до цього.
Ми провели досить багато змін, які можна  втілити  швидко.
Ми скоротили  структуру і скоротили кількість адмінперсоналу.
Ми нарешті добудували і запустили ці 7 сканерів-довгобудів,
які півтора року зависали десь в повітрі.
Ми переглянули  штатний розклад і залишили
за бортом Держмитслужби більше ніж 500 одіозних митників.
Тобто зроблено немало.
Насправді в нас успіхів,
на які розраховують всі люди,
вони будуть в цьому - в 2020 році.
Ви багато пишете про успіхи нової митниці на своїй сторінці в Фейсбуці,
але як фідбек від користувачів Ви отримуєте записи,
що, мовляв, про що Ви розповідаєте? Подивіться, будь ласка,
на кількагодинні черги на кордоні з країнами ЄС.
Це, звичайно  правда. Звичайно, важко очікувати,
що зміна керівництва митниці якимсь магічним способом
має призвести до того, що в нас на завтра з’явилися
нові  пункти пропуску і немає черг, і всі митники
стали ввічливими...
Я розумію бажання людей мати результат  швидше,
і вони мають право це вимагати.
Моє завдання - максимально  активно працювати,
аби ті зміни втілювати в життя.
Щось можна зробити відносно швидко -
ті ж самі ввести сканери. Щось  займає набагато більше часу,
як повна реконструкція пунктів  пропуску.
Це велике будівництво, починаючи з вивільнення землі,
проекту, до фундаменту будівництва, обладнання,
синхронізація  роботи з польською, угорською, словацькою стороною.
Можливо, митниця може працювати на 5% швидше.
Хоча, чесно кажучи, ми оформлюємо фактично без проблем
всі вантажі, які приходять. Пасажирські, автомобільні,
які приходять  з польського боку. Але 5% недостатньо.
Необхідно, аби пропускна здатність кордону збільшилася в 2 рази,
тому що в більшості випадків кордон банально перевантажений.
Польща надала Україні кредит на переобладнання  пунктів пропуску.
Я так розумію, що кредит не використаний.
Чи можете  назвати причину?  Наскільки це погано для України?
Власне кажучи, цей кредит буде використаний в цьому році.
Ми дуже активізувалися в співпраці з польською стороною в кінці 2019-го.
Ми завершуємо процес проектування по тих пунктах пропуску,
які будуть профінансовані за рахунок  цього кредиту,
і дуже розраховуємо, що згідно з графіком у 21-му і  22-му році
всі об’єкти повністю будуть здані. Вони будуть здаватися чергами.
Нова митниця вже  встановила нові сканери,
і за допомогою, в тому числі, цих  сканерів  Ви особисто хочете  поламати,
як Ви сказали, економіку контрабанди. Як саме?
Сканер дозволяє  перекрити досить багато видів порушень.
Він дозволяє швидко, просто, зручно і в комфорті побачити,
не вивантажуючи фуру, не заганяючи її в якісь бокси,
не зриваючи пломби, побачити, що в ній.
Він  може відрізнити, коли за одягом ховають електроніку.
Або коли кажуть, що фура  напівпорожня, а вона насправді забита повністю.
У нього є свої обмеження. Він не може розпізнати,
що коли кажуть, що це одяг секонд-хенд, а насправді це якісь елітні бренди,
які коштують тисячі доларів. Окрім того, це, звичайно,
пришвидшує процес перевірки авто, це звичайно робить його більш комфортним.
Замість того,  щоб під дощем, снігом, холодом, вночі
щось доглядати, щось вивантажувати тощо…
Ми розраховуємо на 15 хвилин від "заїхав" до "повністю виїхав".
Кожен сканер, відповідно, якщо він буде на 100% завантажений цілодобово,
може опрацювати до 100 машин на добу.
Це велика кількість, макроекономічна кількість.
І, звичайно, вони будуть  як знаходити контрабанду,
так і слугувати таким великим бар’єром для контрабандистів.
Якщо ми будемо ловити кожен сьомий вантаж, то цієї економіки не буде.
Кожному стане зрозуміло, що ви все одно рано чи пізно  попадетеся.
І якби кількість тих, хто буде попадатися, достатньо велика,
аби  зробити більшість видів порушень митних правил невигідними.
Чи багато контрабандистів Вас уже ненавидять?
Я насправді думаю, що багато.
І ще більше не просто контрабандистів, які  засвічені  в пресі,
а і представників ось цього… дуже дивної  "екосистеми " навколо  кордону.
Це  саме та "екосистема ", яку ми ламаємо
об’єднанням митниць у єдину юридичну особу.
Бо що в нас там є  в кожній області?
В нас є місцевий очільник митниці. В нас є місцевий очільник податкової.
В нас є голова ОДА, головний поліцейський, прокурор, представник НАБУ, ДБР.
Все це, як би мовити, одна регіональна еліта.
І в  багатьох місцях ці люди щиро вважають, наприклад,
що з ними мають погоджувати призначення керівників митниці.
Вони не розуміють, бо… Як це? Ви не погодили, не прийняли до уваги наші кандидатури?
І ці люди  кажуть, що раніше були нормальні керівники митниці, розуміли все.
А ось ти, Нефьодов,  якийсь керівник митниці такий дивний.
Ну що ж. Я дуже сподіваюся, що ми будемо продовжувати
залишатися для них дивними і будемо будувати Держмитслужбу
на абсолютно нових  принципах.
Ви нічого не сказали про контрабандистів.
Я дуже мало спілкуюся з контрабандистами,
хоча вони весь час намагаються надсилати якихось своїх там емісарів,
якби щось там, знаходитися в якомусь  діалозі. Але так,
я очікую, що зрозуміло, що їм не може подобатися голова митниці, який з ними бореться.
Втім, моя  пропозиція до них дуже проста.
Якщо ви працюєте по закону, то ви працюєте незалежно від прізвищ.
Якщо це не по закону, знов, незалежно від прізвищ чи назв –
західна компанія чи українська компанія, чи якась інша,
то тоді  ви не працюєте, тоді і закон вас карає.
Який результат у боротьбі з контрабандою вас особисто вразив?
Для мене важливо розуміти, коли я бачу, що в мене
зростають, можливо, такі  сухі показники, як доходи держави з одного  долару імпорту
або  середня митна вартість несировинних товарів.
Або коли я бачу стрибкоподібне збільшення  імпорту
по деяких традиційно дуже ризикових категоріях, як, наприклад, автозапчастини.
У нас же не можуть раптово почати ламатися машини більше по всій країні.
Це означає, що якась частина ринку, яка була в тіні,
вона починає  працювати. Якщо не повністю в білу, хоча б сіру,
і ми витискаємо її поступово на світло.
У нас у митній статистиці відсутні цілі категорії товарів.
Таке враження, що вони просто матеріалізуються на території України.
Коли я бачу, що вони з’являються в статистиці, це круто.
Це означає, що ми рухаємося в правильному напрямку.
Можете перерахувати, які категорії з’явилися так раптом?
Насправді в нас великі успіхи. Наприклад, ми почали з кави.
Розчинна кава - зрозумілий ринок.
Раптом виявилося, що внаслідок зміни  правил ризик-менеджменту
бюджет може заробляти  на 20 млн грн. на місяць більше, ніж до цього.
Або візьмемо ринок автозапчастин.
Ми почали переводити оцінку вартості товарів з кілограмів.
Не зовсім не зрозуміла категорія, як можна міряти шини  в кілограмах?
Шини треба міряти в штуках.
Почали  міряти в штуках. Раптово виявилося, що
бюджет почав заробляти на цій категорії на 70-80 млн грн. більше за місяць.
Насправді це круто.
70 мільйонів?
Так.
Категорія автозапчастин і шин - це велика  категорія,
і боротьба там триває, і ми станом на січень ще далекі від повної перемоги.
Ми отримуємо схвальні відгуки від імпортерів мінеральних добрив,
які кажуть, що вперше нам вдається  оформити корабель без хабарів тощо.
Тому я не хочу, аби здавалася ситуація, що в нас, ви знаєте,
ми все побороли, і в нас є виключно тотальні успіхи.
Ні, в нас  дуже складна ситуація, з якої  ми покроково,
як я кажу, камінчик за камінчиком, поступово вибираємося.
Повідомлень багато з Одеси, що там продовжується хабарництво.
Люди постійно платять цим митникам за те, щоб пропустили вантаж.
500 доларів, 1000 доларів…
Ситуація в Одесі дуже складна,  але поступово покращується.
Це ми бачимо по статистичних  показниках, які ми відслідковуємо:
по вартості одного контейнера, по доходності з одного контейнера,
по кількості вантажів, які не пред’являються  до огляду.
Вони просто  стоять і вже наче не потрібні  своїм власникам.
Всіх, хто хоче повідомити про корупцію, писати мені.
У нас вже були  випадки у Львівській області, були абсолютно звільнені цілі зміни,
на які  були підозри в  корупції.
Можете писати особисто мені на Фейсбуці. І недоторканих в  нас точно немає.
Щодо співробітників…Чи вдалося перевести усіх  у нову митницю?
Ми і не хотіли  переводити усіх 11 000 митників  в нову структуру.
Було б  дуже цинічно боротися з корупцією руками тих же самих людей, які володіють,
як в нас на Львівщині  була знаменита митниця, яка володіла Rolls-Royce.
Тому, звичайно, таких людей ми залишили за бортом.
Як Ви їх визначали?
Ми спиралися на відгуки з бізнесу,
ми спиралися на інформацію від правоохоронних органів.
Звичайно, ми дивилися на їхні декларації.
В мене дуже  простий принцип. Якщо ви вже мультимільйонер,
то нащо вам ця важка  неоплачувана державна робота?
Ні! Хочуть працювати.  Більше того!
Хочуть працювати виключно на кордоні.
От їм дуже хочеться працювати на великих пунктах пропуску, на заході.
А ми кажемо, що, можливо, ми вас  переведемо кудись на внутрішні роботи?
Ні, кажуть.  В нас талант стояти на кордоні.
Звичайно, таких людей ми не хочемо бачити  в лавах митної службі.
Чи багато людей стоять біля вашого кабінету та просяться на роботу з цих старих митників?
Або з нових?
У нас класична ситуація.
З одного боку, чесні люди не хочуть йти і працювати на ті зарплати, які є в державних органах.
А з іншого боку є багато людей, які в прямому сенсі
готові давати  хабарі, аби попрацювати хоча б один день
десь в Шегинях чи в Одеському морському порту.
Тому наше головне завдання – це просто відрізнити перших від других.
Як Ви хочете мотивувати нових співробітників?
Приміром, за те, що вони знайшли велику контрабанду?
Власне кажучи, мені просто хочеться підняти їм зарплату до ринкового рівня.
Для інспектора це зарплата, яка дорівнюється зарплаті митного брокера.
І мені б дуже хотілося, щоб до кінця цього року
зарплата рядового інспектора, -
звичайно, ще раз кажу,  не того, хто їздить на Rolls-Royce, а того, хто
пройшов перевірки на доброчесність  і професіоналізм,
вона досягла цього рівня  - приблизно 17-19 тисяч грн. на руки.
Якщо нам цього вдасться досягти, я переконаний,
що великих проблем із кадровим оновленням в нас  не буде.
Який напрямок на кордоні Ви вважаєте зараз найбільш проблематичним?
У нас три основні проблеми, які ми хочемо  вирішити 20-го року.
Це західний кордон з ЄС, це Одеса і контейнери морем,
це поштові й експресперевезення.
Поштові та експресперевезення. Що Ви хочете зробити з ними?
Ми дуже хочемо налагодити процес, коли, з одного боку,
доброчесний отримувач може онлайн оформити посилку
і заплатити мито з картки, з  телефона, нікуди не ходити,
не наймати митного брокера. А з іншого боку,
почати боротися з практикою, коли під виглядом індивідуальних посилок
у країну перевозяться цілі комерційні партії товарів.
Коли на фейкових отримувачів чи людей, які не знають,
що вони є буцімто отримувачами товарів,
завозяться десятки тисяч телефонів чи десятки тисяч пар джинсів.
Це не має нічого спільного з електронною комерцією,
з нормальною ситуацією, що будь-хто з нас може купити в інтернет-магазині.
Це великомасштабне шахрайство.
Якраз чому ці три напрямки - західний кордон, Одеса і пошта?
Тому що вони взаємопроникні, тому що  складається ситуація, коли
ми додатково займаємося, наприклад, Одесою,
то, значить, воно починає їхати через захід.
Ми закручуємо гайки на заході, якісь встановлюємо сканери, обладнання,
міняємо зміни. Вони переключаються на пошту.
Наше завдання - це поступово стискати з усіх боків.
Чи можете Ви сказати, що повністю контролюєте ситуацію на кордоні
з Росією, Білоруссю та  Молдовою?
Ви знаєте, було б великим перебільшенням сказати,
що я повністю контролюю все, що відбувається на митниці.
Якби  це було так, то й реформа була б завершена, і все  було б  добре,
і можна було звільнятися, повертатися назад у бізнес.
Але ситуація там поступово рухається у правильному напрямку
як із точки зору гучних затримань, так і кадрових змін і статистичної якості роботи.
Ви казали нещодавно, що Україна взагалі повністю
не контролювала те, що завозиться на територію країни?
Ні, Україна, звичайно, контролювала те, що завозиться, як контролює і зараз.
Питання в якості цього контролю.
Ще раз кажу, контрабанда – це не питання, яке…
Мається на увазі, що могли завозити небезпечні товари.
...коли є, чи нема. Це питання, скільки її.
Якщо там 1%, ну, тоді ок, з нею мають боротися правоохоронці.
Але, якщо її стає 20%, це вже стає питанням економічної безпеки для країни.
Бо який сенс займатися бізнесом, якщо ваші конкуренти працюють в чорну,
не платять податки, не платять мита, не працевлаштовують легально людей тощо.
Не можемо сказати,  що ми рухаємося від повністю "чорної " до повністю " білої "ситуації,
але  ми робимо її білішою.
Якщо ми візьмемо лише контрабанду, в ідеальному випадку,
якби нормально б усе працювало, наскільки би збільшилися прибутки бюджету?
Можна робити лише якісь опосередковані обрахунки.
Напевно, це  сума, яка вимірюється мільярдами, можливо, десятками мільярдів.
Але, чесно кажучи, виміряти точніше досить важко.
Очікуємо, що вже цього місяця - наприкінці січня -
буде прийнятий закон про єдину юридичну особу митниці.
Очікуємо, що це дозволить таки скоротити
і зробити більш пласкою структуру управління,
так і досягти деяких досить цікавих технологічних змін.
Наприклад, ви приїжджаєте на західний кордон,
але вашу декларацію дивиться тепер не митник зі Львова чи Луцька,
а дивиться з Чернігова чи Одеси. Відповідно, умовно кажучи,
хабар нема кому давати. Бо ви не знаєте, хто з нею працює.
Це  знов-таки, як і всі інструменти, не панацея, але потужний крок.
Ніхто не заважає Вам працювати?
Завжди працювати складно і реформи робити складно.
Але скаржитися на обставини, мені здається, неправильно.
Треба намагатися  в тих обставинах, які є з кадровими,
фінансовими обмеженнями, з тими проблемам, які є в митниці
через якісь інші макроекономічні чинники, на які ми не можемо  впливати,
наприклад, курс гривні чи  економічна активність, давати  найкращий результат.
Саме тому я не вірю в якісь словесні оцінки роботи митниці,
як часто кажуть, що, мовляв, все їде або не їде.
Я  вірю в статистику, в статистичні показники, які ми відслідковуємо щодня.
Я просто щиро вважаю, що в нас унікальний шанс на зміни.
Хоча ніхто не гарантує перемоги,  але я радий,
що  ми принаймні вийшли на поле бою.
Дякую!